gros changement dans la vie de stephenie
elle déménage et à trouver un nouvel
emploi dans un bar prévoyante elle
informe son assureur pour mettre à jour
ces renseignements sitôt au courant qu
elle est serveuse de bar
l'assureur met fin au contrat parce
qu'il ne veut pas d'histoire
stéphanie tout un choc y at il vraiment
des métiers est digne d'être assuré en
vérité les compagnies d'assurance sont
libres d'établir leurs règles en matière
de risques et rappelez-vous que la loi
vous permet en tout temps de résilier
votre contrat
alors elle donne à l'assureur le même
droit dans ce cas si l'assureur
automobile de stéphanie est du type
frileux ils ne surent pas de
propriétaire et d'employés de bar ni de
personnages publics ni d'artistes parce
que selon lui ces professions augmente
le risque
heureusement pour stéphanie les
assureurs ne sont pas tous pareils même
que la plupart d'entre eux seraient
ravis de l'accepter tel quel est le fin
mot de l'histoire
rien ne sert de pleurer un assureur de
perdu dix de retrouvés
[Musique]